[Music]
unsuitable companies say they will not
make a commitment to lowering the list
price of prescription drugs but they say
they would support some administration
proposals to reform the health care
system executives from seven top drug
companies testified before Congress
yesterday they blamed high prices on
barriers within the healthcare system
Americans are projected to spend up to
five hundred and fifty billion dollars
on prescriptions this year that's up
more than 54 percent since 2010 Anna
Werner shows us the bipartisan effort to
address rising costs Pharma executives
all of you that are here today are here
because the way you've been doing
business is unacceptable in a nearly
four-hour hearing on Capitol Hill
Tuesday senators from both parties press
top pharmaceutical executives about
their company's pricing practices for
something which over-the-counter is 200
bucks a month and we're paying $2,600 a
month it is almost as if the taxpayer
has stupid written on their face
the pharmaceutical leaders pointed much
of the blame of soaring drug costs to
middlemen known as pharmacy benefit
managers who negotiate drug prices with
manufacturers and insurers unfortunately
the horribly misaligned incentives
within our health care system often
makes medicines unaffordable for
American patients we need to fix this
two years ago Kathleen Washington told
us the price of her insulin was more
than she could afford I must pay my
mortgage and so if it's a choice between
the mortgage and the it's gonna be to
mortgage the 76 year old says she's
still struggling to pay for that insulin
which can reach as high as $600 to help
make ends meet she relies on free
samples from her doctor it is a disgrace
that you would charge that amount of
money for something that is so necessary
for so many people on Tuesday those
executives would not commit to lowering
the list price they charge for drugs no
one company can unilaterally lower list
prices without running into financial
and operating disadvantages that make it
impossible to do that for
CBS this morning I'm Anna Werner there's
an issue affecting millions of Americans